games like assassin's creed and mirror's
edge demonstrate the potential
application of parkour
especially when combined with other
skills so too do jackie chan movies
being able to put objects between
yourself and a pursuer or being able to
quickly navigate
over and around obstacles could save
your life at any rate is awesome and it
gives you greater physical freedom
to move and to explore and it's good for
you parkour actually shares its roots
with functional training and movement
training
these are all offshoots of georges
hebert's natural method
herbert spoke of the importance of being
strong to be useful
and his ideas were adopted by the french
military in the form of assault courses
known as la parkours those same ideas
were later talked to david bell by his
father
raymond bell who had also served in the
french military
along with sebastian fukan david bell
went on to create the parkour movement
as we know it today
you can also augment this skill with
specific strength and conditioning
and for those non-tracers taking some
parkour type movements and adapting them
into your training
can result in a workout that's fun with
amazing functional benefits
to devise a parkour workout we can turn
to the atsp hierarchy i discussed in my
book
functional training and beyond that
stands for attributes
traits skills proficiencies in other
words
we break down parkour into its component
skills we then break down the traits
they involve
like upper body explosiveness balance
hip stability
finally we can look at the specific
physical attributes we need to train
like fast twitch fiber in the lats or
strengthen the medial glutes often this
means choosing an exercise
looks similar to the movement this is
specificity
it's also a good idea to focus on
explosive movements with a relatively
light added resistance up to about 75
percent of body weight
or even just body weight if we're
looking to emulate assassin's creed
specifically
or the more practical aspects of parkour
we should probably focus on precisions
climb ups swing throughs tic tacs wall
runs
vaults hurdles breakfalls the following
movements can be added to your training
to enhance these abilities
broad jump so kicking off one of the
best movements you can use to
improve jumping in parkour is the broad
jump
so typically when we think of jump
training we tend to focus on
verticals the broad jump is a similar
idea except for you're going
forwards so i guess you could call it a
horizontal
simply by practicing jumping forwards
instead of jumping straight up you
slightly change the
activation of the muscles involved so
this takes a lot of emphasis off of the
knees and it places it on the hips
it's more of a hip hinging movement also
places a great deal of extra emphasis
on the ankles and because you're
mimicking that forward
that horizontal movement and pushing off
the ground in that direction actually
transfers very well
to running speed as well so it's used by
a lot of athletic
coaches i also like this as a movement
for non-tracers because it's a hip hinge
movement that doesn't involve having a
very heavy bar
to pick off the ground which a lot of
people don't have access to especially
at the moment
so it's going to look a lot like a
counter movement jump that means you're
dropping down
low into a squat that's the amortization
phase you're going to be leaning
slightly more forwards as you do
and you're going to swing the arms
backwards then you're going to push off
and forwards through the balls of the
feet and then you're going to land and
absorb that impact nice and gently by
bending the knees
and the ankles and you can use
progressive overload and you can monitor
your progress here by using two cones or
other markers on the ground
to measure your distance and the great
thing about this as well is that it
allows you
to aim for a target so if you put a
towel on the ground for instance you can
try and land on that smaller surface
area
and this is fantastic for improving your
precision for precisions
of course an easy way to make the
movement more difficult
is to add a weight vest and that will
add some additional
resistance another variation that i love
is to take a medicine ball
and to swing that up from between your
legs as you jump this adds resistance
yes but at the same time it also gives
you a little bit more momentum as you're
moving forwards
it turns the movement even more into a
hip hinge and it's essentially like a
jumping kettlebell swing and you can add
a slam at the end as well if you want to
make the movement more complex
skipping skipping is an incredibly high
value movement for training
this improves ankle stiffness which
translates directly to better running
speed
contractions in the calf actually play a
minimal role in plantar flexion during
running
it's all about those tendons even better
it also trains
rhythm rhythm is an underappreciated
component of athletic performance
and has many critical roles whether it's
a fighter trying to break an opponent's
rhythm
also tracer timing their steps to ensure
their good foot is planted
just in time to make the leap bounding
speaking of running faster and jumping
from one leg bounding is another
incredible tool
you can add to your arsenal bounding is
a popular exercise among athletic
coaches
that involves leaping from foot to foot
to cover as much distance as possible
per stride while staying safe of course
this works a little like shock training
with a burkashansky depth jump in that
you'll be training the myotatic stretch
response
leaping back off the ground and
returning energy in explosive manner
as soon as you come into contact the
difference is that you'll be doing this
off of a single leg
as you do when you're running or jumping
in parkour this can translate to
potentially huge gains in running speed
and leaping ability
this can be progressed using cones that
show where the feet should be placed
you can also experiment with consecutive
hops in different patterns too
and moving from side to side will also
improve hip and ankle stability
direction changing and injury prevention
pistol squats pistol squats will improve
your single leg strength
and stability your mobility and your
balance training each side is important
to help you become
more ambipedal this is something i
didn't really touch on in the last video
on ambi dexterity
the ability to jump off either leg is a
huge advantage
when it comes to confidently clearing
gaps interestingly though
athletes tend to be better at balancing
on their non-dominant leg
this makes sense seeing as you balance
on that leg to support yourself
while using the other leg for more
dextrous movements like kicking
balancing on both legs independently is
a quick way to improve your balance for
crossing beams and ledges then
squats i haven't spoken much about
vertical jump training yet which is
because there is far less of that in
parkour
than we might typically assume the truth
is that most jumping is done from one
leg while running
and as jc santana would say this is more
about energy
transfer than production that said there
are definitely times when a high
vertical jump is useful in parkour
and it tends to correlate with many
other useful skills and when it comes to
improving jump height
sticking with the classics is often the
way to go the squat absolutely adds
inches to verticals and especially if
you keep the focus on bar speed
moving explosively during the concentric
portion of the movement
it's also fantastic for bracing the core
and teaching lots of good habits
goblet squat jumps my favorite movement
for improving
vertical jump height at the moment
though is the goblet squat jump
here you simply take a kettlebell or
sandbag and hold it in front of you
then jump straight up as high and as
explosively as you can
this keeps the movement fast and
explosive while also engaging the core
and by putting you in that anti-flexion
position as you try and prevent the
kettlebell from pulling you forward
you're also engaging the erector spinae
and keeping your core nice and stiff
kettlebell swings kettlebell swings are
also a strong option
yes the kettlebell squatting swing is a
real thing and it develops more ground
reaction force than a regular swing
it's not wrong and it won't hurt you you
can also employ the overspeed kettlebell
swing technique
by swinging the weight back down towards
you more forcefully and then absorbing
that momentum to return it back to the
air
climax so the climb up is another
fundamental
movement in parkour that involves
running up onto a wall grabbing the top
and then pulling yourself
up this has a number of different
variations with the most difficult and
impressive and best looking version
being the level five climb up here
essentially grabbing onto the wall
pushing yourself straight up in the air
and then bringing your legs in between
where your hands would have been
so essentially very similar to a muscle
up looks a little bit like a kong vault
but onto the wall this is a very
difficult movement and very few tracers
even can perform it
you're perfectly fine sticking with the
level 4 level 3 i'm not sure what i
would be doing
these variations involve kicking off the
wall more taking more steps
or alternatively vaulting to the side at
the top of the movement
there's a fantastic video about this by
jimmy the giant
which i highly recommend checking out
his channel is a treasure trove of
information he's like a parkour scholar
those familiar with their calisthenics
will immediately identify this as
essentially a muscle up which it kind of
is so a great way to train this of
course
is by practicing muscle ups but we can
also get even more specific
with this by practicing essentially just
the climb up
so you can run against a wall and push
yourself
up lower yourself down and then do the
same thing again for repetitions this is
something that a lot of
tracers do and in some cases they're
able to do like five and ten seconds
which is
amazing you can even do a variation
using a pull-up bar like this
so as you can see in that version i'm
using the wall
as a kind of backboard to kick myself up
making the movement
more similar to what we would normally
be doing
tactical pull-up pavel satsulin's
tactical pull-up so essentially what
this involves
is using an overhand pronated grip as is
the case for a pull-up
but instead of putting the thumb
underneath like you normally would
you're going to put the thumb
on top and what that's going to allow
you to do is to then transition
the movement into the push it's a bit
like the false grip that you see
in ring pull ups but it's also a lot
more like real life if you're holding
onto a wall
or a window ledge you don't have
anything to get your thumb under most of
the time so if you're going to pull
yourself up you need
to use that overhand grip and powerful
recommends doing this with a tight
core using a kind of hollow body
contracted abs
for repetitions and this is a great way
to not only build grip strength but also
to
build the exactly correct pulling
muscles that you're going to need
to mount onto things and climb up things
just as a point of interest notice how
different this is from the way that edu
portal
performs a pull-up his perfect pull-up
involves
bringing his chest back and pulling the
bar all the way up to the sternum
and the idea behind this of course is to
increase range of motion
and the challenge he does in a very slow
and controlled way just goes to show
that
there's no right and wrong way to do a
movement it all depends on the results
that you're
interested in chasing rope climbs i also
recommend throwing in some rope climbs
not only is this a little like climbing
a vertical pipe or lamp post
but it also toughens up the grip like
nobody's business tough hands can be a
huge asset for someone climbing onto
walls
all day dips i do recommend some
weighted dips perhaps on gymnastics
rings to build that pushing strength
here we're breaking the movement of the
climb up down into its constituents
and strengthening the chest and triceps
with isolated repetitions
crawls another movement that should be a
staple of any parkour conditioning
program
something i've talked about a lot
recently you probably saw it coming is
quadrupedal movements
crawls things like the bear crawl or the
lizard crawl the bear crawl is actually
used in parkour to move along beams and
walls and things and it's a fantastic
tool for building your proprioception
and your body awareness because you're
moving the limbs in a asynchronous
manner
across the two hemispheres and if you
want to learn more about that then check
out my
video that i uploaded recently on that
topic but either way
improving your body awareness is crucial
in parkour especially when it comes to
spotting your landing whilst you're
spinning through the air at the same
time like i say you can actually use
this
to tie together different movements this
fantastic way to train the core for
anti-rotation
and you can make it more difficult by
wearing a weight vest by
moving to the lizard crawl which is
closer to the ground and involves
more of a sweeping movement with the
arms and the legs for better mobility
hip mobility in particular
you can even drag a sled which involves
digging into the ground
at that horizontal angle again fantastic
for the quads and for building
speed and power whether you're running
or jumping to cross a gap
whilst i'm on the subject of locomotive
movements and crawls it'll be remiss of
me not to mention
the ground kong also known as the
forwards traveling ape in animal flow
or frogger in gmb fitness and what
you're actually doing here
is a kong vault but on the ground and to
do this you place your hands on the
ground in front of you
and then you jump forwards to bring your
knees and your legs
in the middle to place your feet down of
course this is a fantastic mobility
exercise that helps build your
resting squat which is really useful for
absorbing impacts and
also improving your jump at the same
time it can be used to condition
the chest and shoulders and triceps if
you use it for
higher volume or with a weight vest etc
cartwheels
speaking of body awareness which is
crucial for tracer trying to land a jump
in a balanced position
performing some form of tumbling or
acrobatics is also a great option
too few of us spend any time upside down
or rapidly rotating
but this has a ton of benefits for
cognition agility explosive strength
and more cartwheels are one option as
they are easy and fun to perform
mine are ugly and unstraight but i do
them anyway they also serve as a
brilliant first progression that can get
you towards more impressive aerial
skills
like the aerial or the side flip also
i'm told
or you can practice other movements like
the kip up handspring or break fall for
reps
hollow body rocks core training is
critical
as a strong core is fundamental to all
athletic performance
i've quoted dr stuart mcgill on this
channel countless times saying
proximal stiffness enhances distal
athleticism
what this means is that you need a
strong and stiff core to produce force
from your limbs
hollow body rocks are a movement
borrowed from gymnastics and involve
contracting the core and then rocking
the body forward and backwards
the land push-up of course there are
many more awesome anti-extension
movements you can use too
such as my favorite the la land push-up
check out my various videos on core and
back training to see more suggestions
for anti-flexion
and anti-rotation too
running so perhaps obvious but you'd be
surprised how many people
don't do this is to just run run long
distances to build up your endurance
your cardio but also
the stabilizing and supporting muscles
in the hips and in the core that you
utilize
when you're running long distances and
when you're tired because even though
parkour will often be done in a single
spot it does involve a lot of running
and if you're tired from practicing lots
of jumps
that's when injuries and accidents can
happen so you want to build up good
running form
through lots and lots of repetition it
should go without saying that all of
these really explosive movements
should be practiced with caution so
anything that involves jumping on one
leg or jumping a distance with a weight
all this involves a lot of impact on the
knees and the joints in general
so you need to make sure you're
confident with your air squat and with
your
one-legged squats before you build up to
this otherwise those high impacts
can cause some serious damage the thing
to keep in mind when you're training
is the type of tracer you want to be
what kind of movement are you trying to
achieve
are you into the graceful flowing
movements if so you may prefer to focus
more on mobility
and movement training alternatively you
might be more partial to big jumps fast
movements and straight lines
if that's the case you should focus more
on athletic movements that build
explosiveness and stiffness
or maybe you want to do something
creative and new whatever the case
you start to design the movement by
first designing your strength and
performance
the creative expression ultimately ends
up on film but it starts when you begin
devising your training plan
i hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around
that helps me out immensely let me know
in the comments below if you've ever
experimented with parkour
and whether you think that maybe some of
the ideas from free running can be
applied to your training
if you want to learn more about
functional training then you can either
check out my
physical print book functional training
and beyond which is a kind of
introduction to the whole subject and
that takes you through the history of
functional training
or you can read my ebook and training
program super functional training
that goes into a huge amount of detail
about different forms of training for
the brain for
mobility for strength and conditioning
and it provides a program at the end
that you can use to train all of these
things at once
subscribe if you want more like this and
hit the bell button if you want to be
notified of new uploads
whatever the case thanks so much for
watching this one guys
and i'll see you next time bye for now